did you see those leaked Joker videos
for injustice
- well developer NetherRealm has
officially revealed the Clown Prince of
Crime I'm Matt and wait till you get a
load of this GameSpot news update the
official gameplay video shows us Joker
going toe-to-toe with characters like
Superman and Green Lantern but we also
get to see him beat the crap out of
Robin with one heck of a super move
he looks similar to how he played in the
first injustice but his appearance seems
more inspired by Jared Leto's Joker in
Suicide Squad and to be honest he kinda
looks like the lead singer of an emo
band according to injustice two's
website he's also the last of the bass
games roster to be revealed but be sure
to LIKE and subscribe to stay up-to-date
on all of the DLC character
announcements in Justice 2 hits the ps4
and Xbox one on may 16 the fighting
games website has nine locked character
slots which happens to be the number of
fighters you can get from buying The
Ultimate Edition we'll let you know when
we hear more about these DLC combatants
but in the meantime head on over to our
Channel and check out the official
character breakdowns for poison ivy and
dead shots
[Music]
you
[Music]